[Music]
et sitting down with box office host and
Marie Lizzy
and warning you about today's episode of
box office it gets pretty wild and crazy
anyways we start with Ben Affleck whom I
recently met on a Sunday morning you'll
be able to see him soon in his upcoming
movie Jersey girl to find out what
actually happened between her and Ben
Affleck in this 2004 interview that
resurfaced and quickly went viral
Wednesday morning bring it up today like
Sunday morning I have to put it in
context I did many interviews like that
with Ben Affleck so the day I did that
particular interview that has resurfaced
it was a bit as usual I would say weed
Ben Affleck in the sense that we would
have this game going on I want to make
it very clear it was strictly for the
cameras while the cameras were on while
they were off he was actually very
proper and we talked about many things
he's very knowledgeable about French
culture Quebec politics etcetera I must
admit in Quebec was very very popular
we always got very high ratings networks
were mailed that as we say a lot so it
was viewed really as as a as a fun thing
Anne Murray makes clear she was not at
all the victim and that the way she and
Ben acted toward each other was just for
show very suspiciously firm I have to
say that interview and many more dared
on a show I was producing actually so
again not a victim I really earned
everything that we that we did the full
interview without editing actually
anything out because I thought it was
kind of fun people still talk to me
about it and very good terms still
nowadays now of course with this whole
story I guess it changes the dynamic a
little bit but after yesterday night it
was still very positive I don't want it
to resurface and now be taken out of
context it has nothing to do with
anything improper
well back I think everybody gets the
context you know every time I went into
an interview it was a in-and-out thing
it's not that I stayed there or anything
I mean we I went to and chatted a little
bit then we did this thing on camera and
then I went out so there was nothing
else in the
lead to anything did not go to his room
or anything like that I had felt and any
which point if I had felt uncomfortable
first of all I would have stopped it
right away during that interview or
other interviews actually it was always
within a big movie release context so
they were always like 20 people rooms
anyway it was really not something
intimate
they were always executives agents
cameraman etc and all the people behind
a watch also so they were there were a
lot of people and everybody loved
actually everybody thought it was very
funny
so we do something before he was very
known and the first time he met me it
was more of a serious interview and just
at the end of the interview started
imitating my accent which he thought was
very funny and then it just went from
there and it lasted four years actually
still boyfriends many boyfriends don't
worry about me have seven lovers
I make love with design man one day for
the week
depends what kind of mood I may be
because I take love and like I take
shower once a week every time during
that whole span of interviews I was
always very happily with somebody and so
and very faithful also by doing so this
was purely professional I don't mind
that it resurfaced actually I still find
it funny by the way
but I don't want it to be mixed in with
that whole that whole story and that
Harvey Weinstein story because it should
not be mixed into that story it's
something completely different this was
a game for cameras again we're both we
were like we knew we were doing this
game we had fun with it and that was it
there was nothing else
you